der heutige migrationsgipfel hat einen
großen Fehler das entscheidende Wort der
entscheidende Idee der entscheidende
Gedanke ist nicht diskutiert worden wo
bleibt eigentlich die Diskussion um
einen Aufnahmestopp ja genau richtig
gehört Aufnahme stoppt bedeutet wir
lassen jetzt erstmal niemanden mehr nach
Deutschland kommen weil wir mit
denjenigen die da sind schon genug zu
tun haben war es aber dass alles nur
diskutiert wird im wie gehen wir mit den
noch mehreren Menschen wie gehen wir
noch mit Menschen aus hier und dort um
richtig wäre zu sagen wie gehen wir denn
mit den Menschen um die schon da sind
denn das Schlagen ja äh Bund Länder und
Gemeinden Alarm besser gesagt Länder und
Gemeinden schlagen Alarm und der Bund
hört aufmerksam zu obwohl die Fakten
seit Wochen seit Monaten wenn man
ehrlich ist seit Jahren auf dem Tisch
liegen es ist nicht mehr zu bewältigen
es kommt zu viele Menschen nach
Deutschland aus zu vielen verschiedenen
Gründen und unsere Länder unsere
Gemeinden
jeder einzelne der sich dort engagiert
kommt eigentlich nicht mehr klar hier
ein menschenwürdiges Leben in
Deutschland zu garantieren und das ist
der entscheidende Punkt jetzt zu sagen
Aufnahme Stopp für die nächsten ein bis
zwei Jahre und erstmal hier die
Hausaufgaben machen wie können wir mit
den Menschen umgehen wie schaffen wir
eine faire Verteilung wie können wir
endlich die Abschiebungen Schwung
bringen und wie schaffen wir es dass die
Grenzen dann wenn nicht dicht so doch
sinnvoll gestaltet sind so dass nur noch
diejenigen ins Land kommen die wirklich
einen Anspruch auf Asyl haben oder aber
im Land gebraucht werden als Fachkräfte
das ist die entscheidende Frage und oh
Wunder die ist gar nicht diskutiert
worden heute sondern es ging lediglich
ums Geld es ging um die Bewahrung von
ist Zuständen wie können wir damit
umgehen und das einzig vernünftige ist
nicht gesagt worden und das regt die
Menschen auf ich als Bürger dieses
Landes würde mich wohler fühlen wenn wir
über einen auf Stopp diskutieren würden
statt ständig nur die Folgen von
fehlerhafter Politik zu korrigieren
die entscheidende Frage ist wo bleibt
der Aufnahmestopp oder wenigstens wo
bleibt die Diskussion um einen
Aufnahmestopp von einer falschen viel zu
hohen Zuwanderung in unser Land Schluss
damit wir müssen ehrlich diskutieren was
wir leisten können was Länder und
Gemeinden schaffen können ja ja da ist
das Wort wir schaffen das und es steht
doch unausgesprochen im Raum wir
schaffen das nicht was es zurzeit gibt
ich habe mir einmal was interessantes
angeguckt wie viele Menschen kommen pro
Jahr nach Deutschland es sind noch
Übereinstimmungen Auskünften 200 17
000 ungefähr viele weiß man ja nicht da
kommt dann immer hinterher raus die sind
irgendwie noch zusätzlich illegal
eingereist aber sagen wir mal 200 rund
220.000
das ist ungefähr die Einwohnerzahl von
Mainz also jedes Jahr kommt einmal ganz
meins nach Deutschland das sind ja
ziemlich viele Menschen und was brauchen
jetzt eigentlich 220.000 Menschen um gut
zusammenleben zu können und der lohnt
ein Blick nach genau nach Mainz und ich
habe mir mal angeguckt was meinst so zur
Verfügung stellt damit 220.000 Menschen
dort gut leben können ich will einmal
hier gucken also es sind sechs
Krankenhäuser ungefähr 700
niedergelassene Ärzte 60 Apotheken
40 Schulen staatliche Schulen und noch
mal 40 Privatschulen
118.000 Wohnungen
130 Kitas
400 Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter bei
der Polizei also Polizisten und
Verwaltungsmitarbeiter und 250 bei der
Feuerwehr das alles stellt Mainz bereit
damit rund 220.000 Menschen gut
zusammenleben können damit sie versorgt
sind damit sie einen menschenwürdiges
Leben haben damit sie gut leben können
so wie man bei uns sich gutes Leben
vorstellen kann und ich glaube dass wir
gut daran tun diesen Gedanken auf die
Migrationspolitik zu übertragen was
müssen wir eigentlich bereitstellen und
bezahlen wenn jedes Jahr einmal ganz
meins nach Deutschland kommt 220.000
Menschen genau wir brauchen so und so
viel Schulen mehr mit den Lehrern wir
brauchen so und so viel Ärzte mehr wir
brauchen so und so viel das ist das
Unangenehmste hören manche nicht ganz
Polizisten mehr wir brauchen
Feuerwehrleute mehr wir brauchen die
komplette Infrastruktur für 220.000
Leute in diesem Land jedes Jahr und top
also plus zu dem was wir schon haben da
gibt es vielleicht ein paar Effekte
Manager würden sagen Synergieeffekte
aber wir brauchen ganz schön viel an
Logistik an sozialer Infrastruktur um
diese Idee Menschen in unserem Land ein
menschenwürdiges humanes Leben zu
ermöglichen damit sie sich in die
Gesellschaft integrieren können das sind
wir Ihnen ja schuldig wenn wir sie ins
Land lassen schaffen zu können und erst
wenn wir das sichergestellt haben und
davon sind wir wenn ich alles richtig
verstanden habe meilenweit entfernt erst
wenn wir das sichergestellt haben dann
könnte man einen Aufnahme stoppt Schritt
für Schritt wieder lockern aber erst
dann bis dahin wird jeder vernünftige
Mensch erstmal sagen gemacht man lernt
ja auch nicht zu Hause Leute zu sich ein
500 Leute in der 60 Quadratmeter Wohnung
sondern dann ist irgendwann ein
Aufnahmestopp denn dann kann man nicht
mehr für Essen sorgen dann kann man
keine Schlafgelegenheit mehr
bereitstellen dann hat man all den damit
verbundenen ärgert dass ich Leute zanken
weil sie Not sind dann hat man Leute da
die man eigentlich gar nicht da haben
will jeder vernünftige Mensch wird es so
machen und als Bürger eines Landes hat
man Anspruch darauf dass die Politik
sich so verhält wie man es als
vernünftiger Bürger selber machen würde
also führt an einer Debatte an einer
ernsthaften Debatte um einen
Aufnahmestopp sozusagen ein
migrationsmoratorium kein Weg vorbei und
deshalb muss von heute an diese Debatte
geführt werden
das ist eine sehr sehr gute und richtige
Geste weil sie basiert auf
Menschlichkeit auf einer spontanen
Bestürzung auf das was Mensch sein
ausmacht nämlich sich gegenseitig zu
helfen viel wohler würde ich mich dabei
aber fühlen wenn man vorher die
Hausaufgaben gemacht hätte wenn vor zwei
drei vier Jahren ein Aufnahme Stopp äh
passiert werden wenn die Politik sich
darauf geeinigt hätte wenn wir hier also
geordnete Verhältnisse hätten was
Migration angeht wenn wir wirklich für
jeden einzelnen Menschen das täten was
ihm zugesteht nämlich sich um ihn
individuell kümmern zu können wenn das
alles der Fall wäre dann könnte man
jetzt aus dem Brust tun der Überzeugung
voller Herzlichkeit und Menschlichkeit
sagen ja wir sind für Euch da ihr
Erdbebenopfer in der Türkei kommt nach
Deutschland viele haben mir sicher
Familie Familienanschluss wir sorgen
dafür dass ihr über die schwere Zeit
durch dass sie durch diese schwere Zeit
gut durchkommt und ihr könnt dann zurück
und euer Land und euer Heimat wieder
aufbauen und die wenigen die es in
Deutschland besser finden als bei sich
zu Hause finden dann auch bei uns sicher
eine Zukunft das alles könnten wir als
Gastgeberland machen wenn wir nicht
durch eine vollkommen verfehlte falsche
Migrationspolitik uns in eine Situation
gebracht hätten dass kein Mensch mehr
versteht warum immer alles nur dazu
kommt immer mehr Menschen immer mehr
sorgenfälle immer mehr Probleme immer
mehr Kriminalität immer mehr soziale
Brennpunkte immer weniger
Deutschkenntnisse immer mehr Probleme in
Schulen wenn das alles geregelt wäre
wenn das alles positiv angeschoben
werden wäre die Einladung an die
Erdbebenopfer mit einer viel größeren
ins Brunst auszusprechen als das jetzt
der Fall ist jetzt muss die Frage
erlaubt sein wenn wir schon so viele
Herausforderungen haben mit fremden
Menschen in unserem Land warum bleiben
die Erdbeben Opfer und ihre Angehörigen
eigentlich nicht in der Türkei die
Türkei ist riesig warum immer
Deutschland ich verstehe die Antwort
weil es hier natürlich in weiten Teilen
viel besser ist viel schöner ist
womöglich viel lebenswerter ist als in
einer jetzt auch noch zerstörten Heimat
aber logisch ist das nicht denn
eigentlich sind doch vor allem die
Türken für die Türken da in den großen
Städten ist auch genügend Platz und
jetzt kommt es aller interessanteste wir
bezahlen ja schon jede Menge an
Hilfsgütern und Spenden mit denen in der
Türkei für die türkischen Erdbebenopfer
die Zukunft geplant werden kann und auch
die Soforthilfe geplant werden kann ich
glaube dass hier die große Gefahr
besteht dass vieles verrutscht das
nämlich die Menschlichkeit die in jedem
von uns drin ist blockiert wird durch
eine vorher verfehlte Migrationspolitik
und wir uns jetzt durch die
Menschlichkeit in immer weiteres
Szenarien bringen die er neue Probleme
mit sich bringen das müsste eigentlich
bei einem migrations Gipfel wie heute
stattgefunden hat diskutiert werden es
ist in dieser Deutlichkeit nicht
diskutiert worden sondern es ist wieder
vermehrt diskutiert worden wie wenn eben
Bürokraten über Geldflüsse und
Betten und Zuständigkeiten und
Budgets diskutieren das wird der Sache
nicht gerecht es ist sogar nach meiner
Auffassung extrem problematisch wenn
wenn die Zukunft blicken und eins muss
ich auch noch sagen bei einer solchen
Veranstaltung von dieser Tragweite muss
eigentlich der Bundeskanzler der
Gastgeber sein dann muss der
Bundeskanzler sagen ich mache dieses
unpopuläre Problem Thema zu meinem Thema
und ich löse es und dann bin ich der
Bundeskanzler der Bürger der
Bundeskanzler der deutschen der
Bundeskanzler der mit offenen Armen auch
Fremde in seinem Land begrüßt weil er
dafür Sorge getragen hat dass es Ihnen
hier dann gut gehen kann ein Mann der
das unterlässt und andere
nicht erledigen lässt muss ich
irgendwann fragen lassen ob er die
Kernfragen der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wirklich zu seinen eigenen
gemacht hat bislang lautet die Antwort
nein
[Musik]
mit Blick auf die Ukraine muss man
feststellen eine Million Menschen aus
diesem Land sind bereits in Deutschland
es sind in Polen sehr sehr viele Ukraine
es sind in Tschechien gemessen an der
Größe des Landes sehr sehr viele
Menschen aus dem Kriegsgebiet aber in
vielen anderen Ländern der EU Spanien
Italien
viele andere sind sehr sehr sehr sehr
viel weniger Menschen aus der Ukraine
warum eigentlich die EU ist sich
vollkommen einig dass die Ukraine
unterstützt wird im Kampf im Krieg gegen
den
erpressor Putin und die Russen wenn es
diese Einigkeit gibt und wenn sie ernst
gemeint ist dann muss es diese Einigkeit
und Gerechtigkeit auch bei der
Verteilung der Flüchtlingsströme geben
und das bedeutet dass nicht immer
Deutschland Polen und Tschechien noch
mehr Menschen aufnehmen sondern das auch
hier in der Verteilungspolitik ein
anderer Schlüssel angewandt wird und da
wo man so ausspricht macht man schon
Fehler den die Politik macht
Verteilungspolitik Schlüssel Arithmetik
Mathematik kleine Erinnerung es geht
immer um Menschen und das bedeutet dass
die Länder die die Menschen aufnehmen
auch in der Verpflichtung stehen Ihnen
dort ein gutes Leben anzubieten und wenn
es in einem Land knapp wird wie in
Deutschland jetzt wenn es in einem Land
zu Zerreißproben kommt wie bei dieser
Frage in unserem Land dann ist es nur
gerecht an das Gerechtigkeitsempfinden
der EU und der Mitgliedstaaten zu
appellieren auch wenn es darum geht
Menschen eine Heimat oder jedenfalls
eine Zwischenstation in ihrem Leben
anzubieten wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie